do I look hip yet oh I don't care about
your opinion I do
just kidding welcome to another episode
not too deep with grace helbig the audio
/ video podcast it's a real fun time
here guys clearly I'm not
overcompensating for going to the old
part of age anyway if you're not sure
how this works here's how it works here
on its grace you get a little snippet of
the interview that I do with my guest on
every episode then you get to see us do
a take on a YouTube challenge though
it's my version and it's basically I
take a game or challenge on YouTube
that's pretty stupid ready and then I
make it stupider for you guys but here's
where the audio portion comes in you can
listen to the full interview with my
guests over on iTunes or SoundCloud or
however you killed Rijn do those things
by searching not too deep with grace
Helbig
this week's guest a beautiful idiot
named Chester C I learned that he is
uncomfortable to interview and then ah
we played a game we played a take on the
baby food challenge called the baby food
challenge and I also learned a lot about
his parenting skills my parenting skills
and his ruthlessness with a dart gun
okay so I said I would say this question
but what's up with the doll here it
reminded me of you
uh-oh here's a question for you that I
am very intrigued by tell us three
things that are involved in your worst
story
okay um nurse Oh accident
sorry on a serious note you seem really
close with your mom and that's
incredibly sweet so tell us about it
oh okay that is a sincere question um my
mom Birds me mm-hmm and raised me mm-hmm
and I loved her and this is Judy moving
on I hate it not you're deep with grace
helbig it's always fun when you have
three cameramen that are guys watching
you look at what color your underwear is
I'm going to allow you to tweet whatever
you want from my Twitter account right
now are you serious I am very sorry I'm
really bad at the pressure and coming up
with something I thought this is funny I
just read it back it's not that funny
it's just weird
now I'm intrigued no one will know it's
you until they find out that it's you
they're starting off very simple explain
this photo this photo huh and I told you
this I don't want to post another
shirtless photo ever again all right but
is ready yeah I was happy with the shape
I was in
excellent I don't know where I'm looking
here's what's great here's the here's
the the ego check that I got yeah
narcissistically expecting you know like
you look great so many comments were bro
work out your legs you have chicken legs
I
while you explain it I'm gonna caption
each of these photos this caption I
would say oops where'd my shirt go
d-trix asked me to take a photo mm-hmm
just like that and he photoshopped his
face onto my body and he used it for a
video that's why that photo was taken
oh I'm clear on that one for pose like I
didn't post this okay then you're off
the hook on that one I think
explain this photo um so my cabinet
first heading toward me and I knew it
I'm gonna say this is you doing the
matrix and then you saw a burrito to
your right and you're like who's burrito
is that that's pretty accurate
I'm not sure why the camera guy was
there took a photo but that is actually
what was happening really yeah oh this
is like the 10th photo that came up I
google and search for him that's my
uncle Gary
uh-huh-huh or my great uncle Gary um and
that's his dog Bartholomew is this a
real story uh yeah yeah I he passed away
a few years ago it's getting this
degenerative this is real I'm ranting oh
I just I don't know where are you I
don't know where these people are but
that dog is pretty cool
here's I was a option this photo I
endure that dogged oh yeah that's pretty
good
we are inspired by the baby food
challenge have you heard about this that
happens on YouTube yeah you heard of the
cinnamon challenge okay that's so today
we are playing the baby food challenge
which means that we are each going to
strap on a baby bjorn with a baby inside
of it okay and then the goal is to take
your gun not real guns kids and we are
gonna load them Hunger Games style what
does that mean meaning that once we have
our baby bjorn and our baby on we're
going to step back and when I say go
we'd to run up to the stage load our
guns and we could protect our babies so
just shoot each other if you shoot the
human you get a point if you shoot the
baby you lose two points the first one
three wins can i my little reference the
cameras yes of course if I shoot your
baby you lose two points oh so I don't
want to shoot the baby yo how is this
like the seventh challenge
once you probably secured your baby
bjorn it's time to learn how to use the
gun we're going to start on opposite
ends of the room and when I say go we're
going to run and the games will begin
may the odds be ever in your favor
mine
I'm sorry that was to me that was like
in your deep okay in the face hand the
counselor I got in the deck I'm not sure
if I accomplished my strategy but I
think I got her to shoot my baby right
off the bat yeah because he was like
great I was playing the stretches of
strategy involved there right
Hey went into maternal mode it was like
just throw your baby on the floor and
maybe James Steele feeling better
shooting you directly in the face yeah
at point-blank just that was not right I
minded it here it was so close so it
seems the chess has won the game I don't
I feel like I won yeah that's the way we
hear on not too deep like to make our
guests feel right they they participated
but then they really win oh well see you
guys next time
huh America huh you should not have a
child I know right there you go there
was a little bit of the podcast
interview and a whole lot of game I
should not be hired to assassinate
anyone and Chester should never be hired
to babysit go over to iTunes and listen
to the full interview not too deep with
grace helbig see you later
I don't know
you had a sweet gig